Monsieur Eric Filiol, bonjour
Je vous interview aujourd'hui pour un site internet qui s'appelle Thinkerview
j'aurais aimé avoir
votre qualité d'expertise
sur les récentes fuites de ''Prism'',
sur les fuites que différentes entreprises,
de différents organismes organisent
ou laissent faire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Oh... c'est un vaste débat, en fait ''Prism'' d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
ce n'est pas
le premier cas.
En fait ''Prism'' c'est juste un sous-programme particulier
d'un plan plus général.
Ca s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans un programme que l'on connaît bien qui s'appelle "Échelon"
qui... Dont un des sous-programmes était
''Carnivore''
bref il faut savoir que
le contrôle de la technologie passe par le contrôle des acteurs qui mettent en œuvre cette technologie
donc c'est même plus fort que ça.
C'est les sociétés qui ont été incriminées et d'ailleurs
il manque certaines sociétés
aient laissé fuiter ou laissé
sortir des données
c'est tout simplement, c'est une
obligation
pour les sociétés américaines
de travailler avec l'état
et en particulier les services de renseignements américains, c'est un autre monde
c'est très éloigné de la vision européenne
mais euh, c'est une obligation.
D'abord on oublie que
cette obligation elle tient du ''Patriot Act''
qui est une loi
qui certes a été créée par Bush junior
mais dont les plus
récents développements
ont été signés et validés par Obama
d'où l'embarras de l'administration actuelle.
c'est que elle ne pouvait pas ne pas savoir
Ce sont des plans concertés, organisés
pour le contrôle de la technologie.
- Quelles sont les répercutions pour le citoyen français ?
- Ho bien pour le citoyen français et
pour le citoyen européen je dirais
c'est simple, c'est que
je dirais qu'elles sont peut être préoccupantes pour le citoyen lambda,
mais elles le sont plus pour les entreprises françaises.
Dès lors qu'on utilise
un service comme Facebook
qu'on utilise google comme moteur de recherche,
qu'on utilise un système d'exploitation bien connu,
qu'on utilise un iphone, de toutes façons
les données que l'on met dedans,
et encore une fois il n'y a pas que des données personnelles,
il y a aussi les données de l'entreprise,
ces données, il faut considérer qu'elles sont lues à livre ouvert.
Vous parlez de Facebook.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert sur
Facebook
Quelles sont les répercutions de Facebook sur la vie privée des gens, plus en détails ?
Déjà, d'un point de vue général, je trouve que Facebook c'est un superbe succès
on a réussi à faire la plus grande agence de renseignements privée au monde.
Ca, c'est quand même prodigieux.
Où les gens "leakent" leurs propres données volontairement.
Donc déjà, ça, c'est génial.
Mais c'est vrai, on a découvert un certain nombre de choses.
On n'a pas tout découvert ... c'est que en particulier dans le domaine de la téléphonie mobile,
Quand on se connecte sur Facebook,
l'application Facebook récupère à l'insu de l'utilisateur des tas de données
qu'elle dissimule sur le téléphone.
Alors elle ne les dissimule pas tant que ça, parce-qu'elles ne sont pas chiffrées,
mais elles sont stockées. En gros, l'application Facebook sur Android se comporte comme une véritable éponge.
On sait - d'autres hackers l'ont révélé - que quand Facebook prétend vous confirmer qu'il a bien effacé vos données,
en réalité, ces données sont toujours présentes. Il y a une petite expérience simple à faire
supprimez votre profil Facebook,
supprimez votre compte Facebook,
il suffit d'aller sur une bannière de connexion et de remettre les anciens identifiants, et comme par magie,
votre page réapparaît. Ca veut dire que tout est stocké.
Tout est stocké et on ne stocke pas les choses sans but.
En réalité, il faut voir Facebook comme la plus gigantesque organisation de renseignements
qui ait jamais été faite.
C'est la Stasi à la puissance ce que l'on veut quoi.
- Quel organisme en France peut protéger les gens ? Qui peut protéger les entreprises ?
Quelles sont les dispositions entreprises par l'état français pour nous protéger entreprises, et nous protéger citoyens ?
Alors normalement, on a la CNIL, la "Commission Nationale Informatique et Liberté"
Le problème, c'est que ses pouvoirs sont limités et sont de plus en plus rognés
Notamment par les dispositions de l'Organisation Mondiale du Commerce
par le lobbying extrêmement intensif des multinationales qui font qu'il est de plus en plus difficile
pour la CNIL et les organismes similaires en Europe de mettre ces grandes compagnies au pas.
On a vu toute la difficulté qu'il y a, qu'il y a eu pour contraindre Google à modifier notamment les règles,
soit disant de protection de la vie privée
les allemands étaient moins inefficaces que les français
c'est un problème de moyens mais aussi
de volonté politique
Alors après,
la protection n'est pas un problème technique. Déjà on
est libre d'utiliser Facebook ou pas.
Donc je pense qu'il y a un problème d'éducation,
il y a un problème de rendre les
utilisateurs conscients des risques
mais je pense qu'il y a aussi un rôle
des politiques d'interdire
certaines pratiques
et d'obliger à certains dispositifs de sécurité.
En fait, le problème plus général
c'est quand on est dans une entreprise
le problème n'est pas tellement la technologie c'est le
droit dont elle dépend.
Il y a une différence fondamentale en droit Européen et Français
pour lequel les données que l'on confie à un prestataire
continuent d'être votre propriété.Ca veut dire que le prestataire a une obligation a minima de moyens
pour protéger vos données, alors qu'en droit anglo-saxon, les données appartiennent à ceux qui les traitent.
Un journaliste dont j'ai oublié le nom avait une formule subtile : "Chez Google, le produit, c'est vous."
Donc dès lors que vous lui soumettez vos données, elles lui appartiennent. Il est libre d'en faire ce qu'il veut,
de les donner à qui il veut, de les exploiter commercialement.
Et ça, c'est une différence fondamentale.Donc je dirais que la première règle pour une entreprise,
c'est de regarder parmi les différents prestataires qui s'offrent à elle, de regarder de quel Droit
ce prestataire ou cette compagnie dépend.
Alors c'est difficile, parce que quand on est une multinationale, une grande société française,
il faut regarder si par exemple dans le capital, il n'y a pas des fonds de pension américains, si la société
dépend bien du Droit français.
Ca devient de plus en plus complexe,
et c'est pour ça que je conseillerais
aux sociétés PME/PMI, de favoriser plutôt une offre -
on parle beaucoup du cloud ou de l'hébergement externalisé -
de prendre plutôt des acteurs régionaux qui vont offrir une garantie quant aux dispositions de sécurité
prises sur les données qui leur sont confiées.
- Vous avez parlé des politiques, des législateurs, qu'est-ce-que vous pouvez nous dire sur leur formation ?
Sont-ils prêts ? Sont-ils suffisamment formés pour appréhender correctement les risques
que le numérique comporte ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que ces mêmes législateurs
sont trop soumis à des groupes de pression ?
Est-ce que ces législateurs
sont tout à fait intègres ?
Est-ce que les
législateurs
vont dans le sens de l'intérêt général ?
Vaste question qui a plusieurs aspects. D'abord, il faut savoir
qu'en France, en tous cas, la formation des hommes politiques
est inadaptée à l'évolution du monde technologique.
Nous avons des gens qui ont fait souvent
ce qu'on appelle leur humanité, c'est à dire, c'est une formation plus
droit, histoire du droit
éventuellement, pour les moins littéraires, économie,
mais on se retrouve en
situation où nous avons des décideurs
qui ne comprennent plus rien à la technologie
et qui prennent des décisions, malheureusement qui impactent nos vies.
Il faut savoir que l'informatique,
les technologies de l'information et la
sécurité qui va avec,
maintenant concernent nos vies, quand on va à l'hôpital ,
quand on déclare nos impôts, bref,
dans les moindres faits et gestes.
Ca c'est important de le savoir.
Donc nous avons des hommes politiques qui ne comprennent plus
la technologie.
Si tant est qu'ils ne l'aient jamais comprise un jour.
Alors, ce n'est pas gênant
dans l'absolu, parce qu'on ne peut pas être spécialiste en tout.
Ca veut dire que comme c'est le cas
dans certains pays je pense en particulier
à l'Allemagne qui a su, effectivement,
capitaliser sur
sa communauté de hackers. Ca veut dire qu'il faut être bien entouré.
Il faut avoir des conseillers
qui, effectivement, ont un sens de l'État.
Et je pense que depuis le Général de
Gaulle ce sens s'est beaucoup perdu.
On a des lobbyistes. Alors, je suis désolé,
le lobbying est un terme
on va dire politiquement correct.
En Afrique Centrale, on appelle çà souvent de la corruption.
Il faut quand même
quand on voit comment certains marchés publics
notamment récemment, ont été violés
Heumm... Bon.
Après, c'est un problème de sémantique
on peut dire, mais ça ressemble à ce qu'on critique chez d'autres.
Le problème, effectivement, je crois qu'il faut revenir à une certaine idée de l'Etat,
à une certaine intégrité et indépendance, à une certaine force de caractère,
pour que nos hommes politiques soient entourés
des bons conseillers.
Alors ça touche un autre aspect, c'est la sélection de nos élites
Le problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
représenter l'ensemble de la nation
uniquement
avec une petite fraction sortie seulement de quelques écoles.
Le retard qu'a la France
comparé par exemple à l'Allemagne
qui de ce point de vue là a été très très pragmatique,
c'est que la France est en train de se couper de
toute une fraction importante de la
population
d'une extrêmement grande qualité, alors qu'on a coutume d’appeler les hackers,
alors en France le problème c'est que le mot hacker est  diabolisé
On oublie simplement que ce sont des gens qui privilégient les résultats sur les méthodes
et qui sont capables de gagner une connaissance intime d'un système.
Ce ne sont pas du tout les acteurs malveillants que l'on veut... que l'on décrit.
On confond d'ailleurs souvent avec le mot "pirate" ,
ce qui veut dire que ces gens-là sont diabolisés,
sont complètement écartés du débat, alors qu'ils pourraient contribuer.
On parle beaucoup de  réserve citoyenne
mais si c'est pour le faire uniquement avec des polytechniciens, des normaliens et des centraliens,
on va pas aller très loin.
Je pense qu'il faut que toutes les
bonnes volontés soient à prendre
il faut plus regarder chez un jeune ce qu'il peut apporter à l'État
et non pas ce qu'il a fait entre 20 et 24 ans,
et là, je suis sûr que la France sera un pays qui redeviendra une nation de tout premier plan.
Faut pas oublier qu'il y a un génie français,
et pas seulement sorti de nos grandes écoles.
Moi j'ai coutume de dire à mes étudiants qu'on est
un mélange subtil et aussi
un peu aberrant de Descartes et d'esprit gaulois.
On le voit dans la communauté des hackers français.
On a la chance en France d'avoir une communauté très vive,
très innovante
malheureusement une bonne partie d'entre elle part aux Etats-unis.
Il faut quand même savoir que beaucoup de hackers,
qu'ils soient "junior security hackers"
ou "senior security hackers"
chez Google, Microsoft, Apple, Oracle...sont des français.
Et ça, c'est quand même dommage.
Vous parliez de Microsoft,
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur les contrats qui ont été passés par la Défense ?
On va dire qu'ils ne respectent pas
franchement,
disons, la règle en matière de marchés publics,
et que c'est pas la transparence qui a prévalu.
Mais je vais dire que là maintenant tous les documents
ont été publiés,
et qui prouvent qu'effectivement, il y a peut-être un certain ménage et une certaine pratique
... à revoir.
Maintenant il faut savoir que la France a fait le choix
de revenir de manière très très
importante et totale dans l'OTAN.
L'OTAN impose ses règles, quand je dis qu'il impose ses règles, il impose surtout les produits américains.
Donc c'est très délicat pour nos hommes politiques,
et malheureusement
nous n'avons plus de général de Gaulle depuis très longtemps,
c'est très délicat
de faire marche arrière en tout cas
de réaffirmer une certaine souveraineté
Mais en tout cas on n'aura pas de
sécurité et si on ne passe pas par ça.
- Vous parlez de certaines pratiques
lors du passage de certains contrats avec la Défense,
est-ce que vous pouvez développer ?
Ben disons que
le lobbying, et disons des
des règles particulières
s'appliquent alors que le marché est public,
les règles du marché public devraient s'appliquer
On a vu tous les documents, on a vu qu'effectivement c'était pas la transparence.
En particulier en France il y a une obligation,
quand vous passez un marché
c'est de toujours
prendre en priorité l'offre logiciel libre quand elle est présente,
quand elle se présente.
Encore faut-il la susciter.
Or dans le cas présent,
lors du passage du marché,
on ne s'est pas assuré qu'il y aurait des gens venant du logiciel libre,
qui pourraient proposer une alternative.
- Que sont devenues ces personnes qui ont signé ces contrats avec Microsoft?
Alors, on va élargir un peu le débat,
mais en France il y a une règle qui veut que
tout haut fonctionnaire, militaire ou non,
quand il quitte l'administration, a
obligation de ne pas travailler pendant cinq ans
dans l'entreprise avec laquelle il
a travaillé étant fonctionnaire.
Je laisserai...
les personnes qui regardent cette vidéo faire une petite recherche
et regarder où vont certains de nos haut fonctionnaires, par qui ils sont recrutés,
et on verra que
c'est une règle qui malheureusement est régulièrement bafouée.
- ... et le devoir de réserve ?
Alors c'est plus que le devoir de réserve , le devoir de réserve s'applique quand on est en poste.
- Donc le délais de carence ?
Le délais de carence c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler un délai où, on va dire...
alors je ne sais pas si c'est une clause de non-concurrence ou euh...
en fait il y a obligation de ne pas travailler dans un domaine ou dans une société avec lequel
on a passé des contrats.
- Très bien, un dernier mot,
Qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire, votre perception sur les whistleblower ?
Julian Assange, Jeremy Hammond, Bradley Manning
- Alors je pense que...
- Aaron Swartz
Je pense que ces gens là ont un rôle positif,
d'un autre côté ça me dérange parce que c'est quand même le triste spectacle que...
d'abord il faut savoir que l'information vient le plus souvent, est d'origine interne.
Alors certes, on pourra toujours dire que
ils ont révélé des choses qu'il
était bon
alors qu'il était bon ...en tout cas
qui intéressaient et qui mettaient à jour certains faits.
Maintenant ils l'ont livré d'une manière peut-être dans certains cas irresponsable
en tout cas ça témoigne d'un malaise et d'une déliquescence de la société.
- Vous faites le parallèle avec Vladimir Vetrov ?
L'affaire "Farewell", ce russe, lassé de cette hiérarchie corrompue,
qui a fait fuiter des renseignements auprès des services français ?
Sauf que je ne le mettrais pas sur le même plan.
Farewell l'a fait risque de sa vie
et il l'a fait en sachant qu'il resterait anonyme.
il l'a fait parce que je pense que c'etait un idéaliste pour autant que je le sache.
Effectivement je pense qu'il était,
que c'est quelqu'un qui effectivement
était peut être dégoûté de certaines pratiques
ou avait compris que le monde avait changé
On ne peut pas nier le fait que certains de ces whistleblower ont un certain égo,
Et il est difficile de savoir quelles sont leurs motivations réelles.
Moi je trouve préoccupant quand même qu'une société
parce que des whistleblower il peut y en avoir dans la société française,
moi je pense que ça illustre plus le fait que les notions de loyauté,
les notions de fidélité, ou disons...
C'est une forme de vol, quand on prend des données qui ne sont pas à soi et qu'on les met dans la place publique
hors de tout contexte, ça pose quand même des problèmes
Mais je pense que c'est révélateur du fait qu'on est une société qui est de plus en plus malade,
où c'est le règne de l'argent, le règne de la puissance,
et voilà... C'est juste un révélateur.
Donc après, ce qu'a révélé Assange, ce qu'a révélé Snowden,
effectivement c'est intéressant,
maintenant ce ne sera sans poser des  problèmes de...
disons de sécurité nationale et internationale.
Je pense qu'il faudrait peut-être
effectivement mettre en place un certain nombre de
mécanismes, pour que...
les whistleblower puissent le faire
mais que ce soit quand même... je vais pas dire "contrôlé" parce que le mot est...
- Protéger législativement les whistleblower ?
- Oui, oui... mais ça existe déjà pour l'administration fiscale.
C'est un problème de légalité, là on favorise vraiment des gens qui,
à mon sens, alors je peux me tromper,
agissent quand même beaucoup par égo,
agissent de manière  assez souvent irresponsable par ce qu'on oublie que
l'affaire Wikileaks a quand même jeté en pâture des noms propres,
des gens qui étaient des serviteurs de leur État.
Après on peut ne pas être d'accord avec l’État américain,
mais ce sont des gens qui ont un idéal et qui servent leur patrie
je pense qu'on n'a pas le droit de le faire de cette manière là
- "Prism" a été précédé par un programme qui s’appelait "Stelar Wind",
qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'un programme secret,
qui est capable de faire un mapping intégral d'une population, d'une entreprise,
sur les habitudes de consommation, les habitudes de comportement d'une population ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une façon que l'Etat, exsangue par une crise financière,
a pu trouver pour prendre la température de sa population,
et pouvoir encadrer de futurs ou de potentiels mouvements de rébellion ?
- Là, vous parlez de Google là.
Google c'est ce qu'il fait, il y a des outils comme "Collusion"
qui montrent que dès qu'on fait la moindre recherche de toutes façons on est déjà mappé
et qu'on reçoit des tas de trucs.
Alors après il est vrai que, il y a deux tendances intéressantes
c'est qu'on on se préoccupe beaucoup, alors on parle beaucoup du "Big Data"
mais ça c'est, disons,
le terme marketing d'un truc qu'on connaît depuis longtemps qui s'appelle le data mining,
qui recherche effectivement des grosses tendances.
Ce qui est effectivement clair et ce qui est intéressant dans la question c'est que,
cette technique là s’intéresse maintenant moins aux grandes tendances
que ce qu'on appelle les signaux faibles,
les signaux précurseurs.
Ce qu'en data mining on appelle la recherche d'outlyer
Effectivement, alors...
je serais très étonné que des projets comme ça n'existent pas,
maintenant sont-ils secrets ? sont-ils...et tout...
Mais je dirais à la limite, n'importe quel décideur
et homme politique, je dirais que s'il ne le faisait pas il serait inconscient et incompétent.
Après faut voir dans quelles conditions c'est fait, dans quel but et autres.
Mais il est vrai que ces techniques là sont très intéressantes.
Et d'ailleurs ça nécessite la collecte d’énormément de données.
On l'a vu, beaucoup de bouleversements stratégiques et
géostratégiques,
On peut parler des révolutions 2.0,
On regarde ce qu'il se passe dans le monde,
beaucoup n'ont pas été forcément prévues,
peut-être parce que ces plans là n'étaient pas encore actifs.
On s'aperçoit, alors c'est toujours facile à postériori de dire si on avait fait ça et ça on l'aurait vu,
il est clair qu'effectivement ça va devenir, si ce n'est pas déjà le cas,
une orientation technologique très très importante ou en tout cas de tout premier plan.
- Qui peut se révéler dangereuse ?
- Après c'est.. effectivement, si le signal faible c'est la préparation d'attentats terroristes
où tout le monde se félicitera qu'on puisse les identifier,
les identifier et les parer.
Parce que le citoyen, quiconque a une famille veut être protégé.
Si maintenant il s'agit d'anticiper des mouvements contestataires.
Vous savez, un résistant c'est un terroriste qui n'a pas réussi.
Dans certains pays on l'appelle résistant, on l'appelle terroriste, c'est juste un problème de sémantique
et de référentiels.
Voilà, pour l'instant vous savez...
En Syrie, si vous devandez a Bachar el-Assad ce sont de dangereux terroristes.
La perception n'est pas du tout la même.
- Est-ce que vous avez une préconisation, un conseil,
pour les générations qui nous
écoutent, les générations peut être futures de hackers,
qu'est ce que vous pouvez leur laisser comme conseil ?
- Je pense que c'est de garder l'esprit ouvert et l'esprit humble, et surtout de
d’essayer de ne pas lutter, aussi de ne pas céder aux sirènes technologiques.
On parle de PRISM ou ????
C'est qu'on a le droit, on a le pouvoir, de ne pas utiliser Facebook, de ne pas utiliser Google.
Il y a des alternatives, il y a un très beau site d'ailleurs,
qui s'appelle prism-break.org
qui pour chaque logiciel et technologie qui est apparenté à PRISM,
donne, assez souvent d'allieurs, l'alternative dans le monde du logiciel libre.
Voilà, je pense simplement que,
je pense qu'il faut éduquer les populations et les jeunes font partie...
font partie des gens qui éduqueront plus tard, donc il faut qu'ils soient ouverts aux autres.
Il faut s'assurer de transmettre la connaissance, la connaissance ne peut pas être une denrée commerciale,
commercialisable.
Et il faut tout simplement exercer son droit de citoyen,
on aura soit de la liberté soit de la sécurité mais on aura pas les deux.
- Monsieur Filiol, qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'exception culturelle ?
Comment ça a été amené ?
Et est-ce qu'on a oublié certaines choses dans l'exception culturelle française ?
- Je pense qu'on peut avoir une culture libre que quand on a déjà de la sécurité.
Et je trouve anormal que dans les accords de libre-échange
on n'ait pas inclus à coté de la fameuse exception culturelle
on n'ait pas inclus prioritairement les
produits de sécurité.
Ce que font déjà les États-Unis,
il est interdit aux États-Unis,
de s’équiper s'agissant de sécurité de produits non-nationaux.
Violant d'ailleurs par ailleurs les accords de libre-échange.
Je pense que ca devrait être obligatoire de rendre les produits de sécurité et les technologies de sécurité
une chose essentiellement nationale
et donc de la faire figurer aux liste des exceptions des accords de libre-échange.